-Pour moi, la France
c'est Alain Delon et De Vinci.
c'est Jean Cocteau.
-Pour moi la France,
c'était le standard de Molière.
-Pour moi, la France c'était
"Pierrot le fou" de J.-L. Godard.
-Pour moi, la France
c'était Nicole Berger..
..dans le film "Blé en herbe".
J'avais 14 ans, à l'époque.
-2 000 Français résident à Tokyo,
20 000 Japonais vivent à Paris.
Ils ont leurs boutiques,
leurs restaurants,
..leur journaux, et tout près
de la place du Trocadéro,
..une école qui essaie de préserver
les bonnes habitudes japonaises.
[Les enfants chantent.]
...
Les Japonais sont nés sur une île
où le premier droit est un devoir :
..respecter l'autre
et savoir-vivre ensemble.
Résider en France est
pour certain un soulagement,
..pour d'autres un bouleversement.
-Ce qui m'a choqué
à la vie quotidienne à Paris,
..c'est les Français qui rentrent
à la maison sans se déchausser,
..les Français garent
leurs voitures sur les trottoirs,
..les Français ne respectent pas
les feux rouges...
Dans les métros, il y a des gens
qui passent sans payer le billet.
-Moi, j'ai trouvé comme défaut :
..les Français ne sont pas
obéissants... Autres défauts :
..les minutes des Français
sont très longues.
Quand quelqu'un dit :
"Attendez une minute",
..on attend 5 ou 6 minutes.
-Comme qualité, j'ai trouvé :
les parents jouent beaucoup..
..avec leurs enfants, les Français
gardent beaucoup la nature,
..les Français laissent les places
assises aux personnes âgées.
Comme défaut, j'ai trouvé :
les Français mangent en marchant,
..les Français garent leurs voitures
en abîmant celles des voisins,
..les Français font beaucoup
de grève, ils se mettent..
..en colère facilement, les
Français ne sont pas accueillants.
[Piano.]
...
-Aujourd'hui, j'ai vu..
..un jeune garçon qui a glissé sur
la route, il était tout mouillé.
Tout le monde a regardé
comme si c'était un cirque.
C'est incroyable,
je n'ai jamais vu ça au Japon.
Vous êtes froid ou quoi ?
-Paris est beau,
..mais je ne peux pas dire
que je suis amoureuse de Paris.
Les gens ne sont pas très gentils...
Ils me font peur...
Ils se fâchent souvent...
Moi, quand je me fâche,
je ne le montre pas..
..pour ne pas blesser les autres,
mais les Parisiens, si.
[En japonais :]
-Il me semble que la différence
entre les Français et les Japonais,
..c'est que les Français croient
que l'homme est né foncièrement..
..mauvais, et ils s'en méfient,
alors que les Japonais croient..
..que l'homme est né foncièrement
bon, et ils lui font confiance.
-Peut-être que ce climat
est dû au fait..
..que l'enseignement en France
est basé essentiellement..
..sur l'accumulation
de connaissances.
Alors qu'au Japon,
..on insiste beaucoup
sur l'enseignement de la morale.
Dans nos classes,
..on invite souvent les enfants
à réfléchir sur des formules,
..telles que :
"Il faut penser aux autres..
"..et il faut aider son prochain
quand il est dans l'embarras."
[En français :]
-L'amour avec les Français
est un peu bizarre.
Au Japon, il y a
entre amour et sexe...
Très grande distance
et très sérieuse.
Mais ici...
Quand on se connaît,
on couche tout de suite,
..même avec les copains
ça arrive souvent...
Et après l'amour,
..on fume, on téléphone :
.."Bonjour, maman.
Comment vas-tu ?..."
Ils ne sont pas trés sérieux,
..il n'y a pas beaucoup
de sentiments.
C'est comme de la gymnastique.
-J'ai un copain qui me disait :
.."Je suis fatigué aujourd'hui
car j'ai fait le sport au lit."
J'ai compris que
c'était de faire l'amour,
..mais c'est terrible
de dire des choses pareilles.
Ils disent "sport au lit".
Ils font l'amour comme on bouffe,
comme on mange, ou prendre un café.
Enfin, c'est très facile pour eux.
Mais je trouve que c'est...
Pour nous, c'est
quelque chose de très secret.
-J'ai dit mon nom.
"Ca ne fait rien ma petite biche,
mon petit lapin,
"..mon petit poussin..."
"Mais je ne suis pas lapin,
"..je ne suis pas poulet, moi !"
[Elle rit.]
-Les Français disent toujours
"Je t'aime, je t'aime..."
Ca ne finit jamais.
"Ma chérie, est-ce que
tu m'aimes ?..."
Mais je crois qu'on n'a pas
besoin de dire toujours ça.
Quand j'étais petite,
avec mes parents,
..on était tous les trois
à regarder un film à la télévision,
..et soudain, ma mère se levait
pour aller faire du thé.
Elle est revenue,
elle a mis un verre de thé..
..devant mon père.
Mon père la regardait, il m'a dit :
.."Ah tiens, justement,
je voulais boire un thé."
Vous comprenez ? Comme ça,
on peut ressentir l'amour.
On n'a pas besoin de dire "Je
t'aime", ou de regarder les yeux.
Avec ça,
j'ai compris qu'ils s'aiment,
..qu'ils sont vraiment ensemble.
Une femme et un homme, c'est...
Voilà.